salut on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on sort
le 15 ou le 15 août les vidéos personne
personne mais regarde on est en plein
milieu de l'été c'est un jour férié tôt
on sait bien petit cadenas un truc un
peu de schille ça c'est un cadenas qui
hyper intéressant parce qu'il a été
fabriqué par un indien qui s'occupe
d'une gamme qui s'appelle les constantes
tic donc c'est des cadenas et des cas
c'était un petit peu antique là c'est
typique et des kanaks utilisé en fait
les indiens et probablement les maharaja
parce qu'il fallait plusieurs clés pour
ouvrir le cadenas et avec plusieurs
personnes constanty que ça vous fait
peut-être penser à l'ats jean-claude
constantin mais pour une fois ça n'a
rien à voir et bien non ça tout à voir
car sinon je ne comprends pas et la
gamme constante xla game un petit peu le
truc anciens de constanta jeu voilà donc
pour le 15 août j'ai décroché mon
téléphone je fais à l'eau gilbert de
l'insoluble il m'a fait oui fabu j'ai
fait depuis quand tu m'appelles fabo
fait parce que tout le monde tu appelles
fab au hockey c'est toujours mieux
qu'olivier est ce que tu aurais un
cadenas un coach il est tout pour sortir
le 15 août la fée oui je t'envoie un
indien je fais quoi tu veux dire un look
black trop long j'ai peur d'en venir à
bout rapidement parce que ce genre de
cadenas ça me parle un petit peu si
c'est le cas je propose que loïc face ce
cadenas ça te dit du coup tu dois pas
être là pendant le tournage j'ai donc on
a trois clés on a ce gros cadenas kaki
effet attaqué lourd bon ici on sent une
résistance là très clairement donc il va
s'ouvrir comme ça et c'est gros truc en
laiton c'est un peu comme les quatre
cannes nat 2 2 kilos que lui j'avais pas
aimé par contre il n'y a pas de grand
secret possible je pense qu'il va
falloir l'attaqué
bien sûr bien sûr je faisais une petite
exploration
alors ça ne s'emboîtent pas on a envie
que ça s'emboîte mais ça s'emboîte pas
et est ce que si ça s'emboîte est ce
serait pas juste un
cadenas
n'ont pas inquiété
là par contre on
mais ici je veux dire des sacs est ici
ou des choses comme ça pour pâques loïc
qu'il entende ce que je lise auger pas
ça ça va très très bien dedans alors
est-ce qu'on peut tourner ah oui
ça ce délice bien c'est une affaire qui
roule
alors qu'est ce qu'on à l'intérieur rien
de spécial mais l'impression
est ce qu'on a ici à l'intérieur on a
cette chose là
qu'elle est la seule à huy a b c varie
donc lui si je le mets là au bout il ya
un truc qui s'enclenche
ce qu'il est ah ouais
ça lui comme ça je trouve ça très joli
et très satisfaisant on est le 15 août
là pour vous ça veut dire que je vais
annoncer dans quinze jours l'arrivée de
mon nouveau spectacle qui va se jouer à
paris d'octobre à décembre j'ai pas j'ai
pas fais d'exploitation parisienne
depuis 2015 et après qu'il va partir en
tournée dans tous les pays francophones
si vous voulez que je vous prévienne
quand je viens chez vous c'est vraiment
le truc le deal c'est un collier de vous
spammer sur youtube et sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez un lien dans la
description vous inscrivez et je vous
envoie un mail que pour ça ces jeux spam
pas c'est si je viens près de chez vous
je vous envoie un mail pour le dire
avant même de l'annoncé sur les réseaux
incroyable ce qu'il ya dedans sommes pas
s'il vous arrive pas trop bien à
comprendre la mécanique qui m'a permis
de faire ça mais là il y avait il y
avait donc deux étapes et là il ya comme
un petit trou de un petit trou de ça oui
ok là ça s'enclenche si je vais dans ce
sens là
j'ai rien fait de spécial
enfin une difficulté en attend ça existe
et ça n'est pas vu ça vous l'aviez vu
vous ça dites moi de là commentaire vous
aviez vu ce petit truc
c'est pas ça qui a une botte de foin
c'est trop stylé
ça ça fait rien elle a attendu coup-ci
j'enclenche est ce que lui du coup ils
font un truc
[Musique]
ces domaines là comme ça il faut
vraiment de l'enclencher
hockey lui peut-être qu'il faut pas de
l'enlever sommes peut-être qu'un notre
truc à faire avec vous un moment oui
c'est un cadenas trois clés c'est génial
de faire l' inverse comme j'ai tout
davis et je vais essayer de surobi c'est
pour voir
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon pas très dur on va pas se
mentir par contre est satisfaisant
magnifique et une ouverture à trois clés
c'est un vrai petit objet de collection
j'adore ça regardez comment c'est ouf
c'est incroyable juste votre même temps
j'ai mis j'ai pas leur sueur sur la
caméra mais je pense qu'on va pouvoir
défier le loïc voir un peu si toutes ces
années à monter des castes est allé
tourner et surtout à les monter je pense
qu'il a il a bouffé plus de 4 de castle
que n'importe qui ici on va voir si ça
lui a donné des skills dans la
résolution de cassettes alors je leur en
mettre à zéro lolo bien faire un casse
tête en fait combien de temps
cette minute que ça tourne sept îles
merci salut je vais aller bouquiner un
super livre avec tin d'astuces de
mémoire tu connais fabien olicard vous
apprends des choses non non ça s'appelle
mémoire vous avez le pouvoir il ya le
visuel qui vient d'apparaître là qui
bouge un petit peu avec dans du ça parce
que c'est l'été avec des vagues tu
comprends c'est en train de se passer
la mouette d'anton il peut rester là ont
bien sûr
non non j'ai juste entendu que tu m'as
dit d'un coup à lolo tu perds un casse
tête un bon jour bien
c'est une micro il a tombé alors qu'à
cela
je pas tout non il y en a où je serai
vraiment pas compétent pour le faire il
fermait vraiment les trucs avec sa danse
a fait une petite bague tu es là ça va
bien frais roman culte et
si on fait une phase d'exploration
rapide on se rend compte que il n'y a
pas d'ouverture de type pour rentrer une
fente une grosse vente de type ce crash
sinon ça n'a pas
de fermetures éclair on a donc trois
pelés est ce qu'il ya un truc est monté
de me dit ce serait un peu compliqué
dans un truc en métal de mettre des
aimants généralement tu me mets du bois
parce que j'ai fait un peu des cassettes
et après des aimants tailler des petits
des p'tits louis la phase d'exploration
du coco des petits zigouigouis la sacer
de souffrir comme ça
ça ne rentre pas ça sonne et est fabien
toi dans toutes les vidéos tu dis il
faut essayer même si parfois ça semble
improbable faut essayer pour aller
jusqu'au bout du truc sherlock holmes se
disait lorsqu'on a écarté l'impossible
tout ce qu'il reste aussi improbable
soit il était forcément la vérité j'ai
vu que ça pouvait pénétrer comme ça
titre oui tout à fait je tourne en eau
passe assez satisfaisant ça oui oh bah
ça vient là hop la has est venu
je me mettais à l'envers
ah oui
c'est fini là non non ok
ok donc là à a tenu à l'aca c'est la
goutte à goutte est donc là je vais plus
loin c'est cadeau ok donc là on a un
autre petit zigouigouis ou là on a une
fantasy gouy qu'est ce que je tente ont
promis
ça va permettre quelque chose
ça j'ai l'impression que ça peut rentrer
là mais peut-être plus tard s'il bon je
vais essayer le obvious c'est à dire
mettre sa dedans attention qu on voit
bien là de caméras parce qu'après le
gall c'est vrai comme ça j'ai tenté de
dents et j'entends un le sens choyé ya
quelque chose qui résistent mécanisme un
petit qui chante réside d'ailleurs
résiste au hockey tu étais riche en deçà
d'accord merci est ce que c'est le sort
un petit peu le zygo
on va tenter en service donc là je mets
cette clé la savate eût suffi toi
maintenant à haut
potentiel voilà le vrai plus on a des
trucs dans la même ou alors le mec il a
dit c'est au club les efforts pour faire
son intéressante we went organise une
vie bien diriger h le tennis organise
une petite soirée je te la beauté très
gentil non mais où tu oublieras vite si
on te fait danser sur une musique sans
âme par exemple
qui tu réalises que la vie n'est pas là
le matin tu te lèves sans savoir où tu
vas à c'est un peu ça et bien résisté
prouve que tu existes cherche ton
bonheur partout à va refuse ce monde
égoïste d'accord je fais ton coeur qui
assistent ce monde n'est pas le tien
bien batwa signe et persiste résiste
donc là j'ai réussi un pari est loin de
suffire mais tu aurais je pense mais je
pars sur la résistance
c'est dommage
oui je pense que je suis pas loin pas
loin il y avait quelque chose avec les
futurs cette clé qui rentre là je me dis
si ça ça entre la [ __ ] mais pourrait
vraiment les gens pour ouvrir leur
cadenas c'était galère points comme en
fait c'est là la seule the sportif c'est
tout
j'ai entendu un son qui me satisfait
m'en plains pas
[Musique]
comment
ah ouais et là je fais comme fabien ah
ouais mais c'est génial en fait à
l'intérieur j'ai pas si vous voyez mais
là en fait on voit jamais vraiment bien
à chaque fois tu dis ça c'est vraiment
bien [ __ ] et non c'est vrai que si
c'était un mémorable là je sais pas si
vous voyez mais voilà vraiment l'avouer
ils ont bien vu là
en vrai qu'il est très satisfaisant est
bien celui-là on vous le fait pas gagner
sur instagram sur site a en fait gagné
sur mon instinct est bien celui-là on
fait gagner sur mon instinct qui
apparaît ici ça c'est l'instar de fabien
et ça c'est du chat de fabien a ouï fm
alors voilà donc n'hésitez pas je vous
mettrai les conditions drastiques gêné
pour le gagner merci pour cette
invitation je ne sais pas si j'ai été
plus rapide je pense que non mais j'ai
bien kiffé petit à outreau oui merci
d'avoir regardé
la vie qui était devant vous et de
l'apprécier pour résister et prouver que
vous existez dans les liens de la
description vous trouverez les liens le
linceul casse tête chacun a pris le
cadenas de mon nouveau livre mémoire
vous allez pouvoir dire ça avant la
rentrée c'est à la salle de la prée
plaisir et puis le petit mail aussi pour
hommes pour que je vous prévienne quand
je passerai en spectacle vers chez vous
et qu'est-ce qu'on mettra comme dernier
lien un truc vert une recette à base de
quoi se nourrit parce que j'aime pas du
tout ouais ok mais un truc à l'air bon
quand même oui mais blizzard moyen du
fenouil c'est ça pensez à vous abonner à
lacq et la vidéo à partager des moments
agréables avec les gens que vous aimez à
très bientôt